mr barrison
when the court's making a ruling i don't
expect to see you put your head down on
the table again
you understand me
it's inappropriate to do that
if you disagree with my rulings that's
fine
i don't want to see you put your head on
the table again
all right and counsel do either of you
plan on mentioning and opening
statements the fact that
mr barryson has been incarcerated i know
it may come up during
expert testimony we take pains to avoid
that
i will not be
mentioned nor do i expect any mention of
um the length of time between the
incident and
today's trial
you weren't planning on mentioning that
were you mr blinkist
now obviously it has relevance on
to the extent that witnesses memories
may fade because of so
obviously it'll come up on
cross-examination i just don't want any
inferences to the jury about how long
it's taken this case to come to trial
because a good part of it was due to the
pandemic
and that was in control of no one
all right you ready mr shellhorn yes sir
all right you could be using the podium
all right very good
all right bring the jurors in
yes
um
uh
let's go
yes
so
all right if you seated everyone
thank you members of the jury we are
ready to commence uh with the trial
beginning with opening statements uh mr
shellhorn
may please the court
counsel members of the jury
good morning thank you again all for
being here today and for serving on the
jury
411 west mill road is an equestrian farm
a 50-acre equestrian farm and training
facility located in washington township
new jersey
when you turn from west mill road onto
the property there's a long driveway
that goes back almost directly through
the center of the property
the first thing you see on your left is
a white farmhouse that's been subdivided
into several
smaller living areas that are
interconnected but basically separate
areas for people to live and behind the
farmhouse there there's a parking lot or
a little driveway right
and as you continue up the long driveway
through the middle of the property it
comes to a slight rise and then it
descends down into a parking area where
you can see the real reason that people
come to this property this farm that's
sometimes known as hawthorne hill
and that's a training facility there
it's an equestrian training facility to
the right there's a long stable with a
number of stalls for dozens of horses
there are outdoor training arenas and
fields for the horses to go through
their training and for the riders to
learn and train
connected to the stable through a
hallway is a
locker area with various different
equestrian materials and equipment
saddles things of that nature and then
that leads into what's called the
clubhouse
now if you take a step back out to the
parking lot you can also get into the
clubhouse through a large front porch
and then you walk through an opening and
an entrance way and then you come into
this clubhouse which is basically like a
long lounge it's almost the entire width
of the building it has a kitchen on the
right a long table a row of walls the
entire wall is glass and it looks out
onto an indoor training arena
there are comfortable couches chairs
things of that nature there's a pool
table off to the left there's a small
office to the side
and you'll notice when you see some of
the pictures during the course of the
trial that the walls all have various
photos and pictures of horses and other
equestrian related things
there's also a number of awards ribbons
medals
many of them earned and awarded to the
defendant in the trial michael barriston
now i expect you'll learn during the
course of the trial that the defendant
was an accomplished equestrian he
trained and wrote in a form of
equestrian called dressage which for
those of you who may not be familiar of
it you may have only seen it once or
twice in the olympics it's a form of
horse riding where the rider guides or
directs the horse
through a series of predetermined
specific motions or steps
and you can imagine it takes great skill
for the rider to be able to guide the
horse through those predetermined steps
or movements but it also takes a great
deal of training for the horse to learn
those things and to be able to do that
and you'll hear about how the defendant
operated his business ferris stone
dressage
not just at that property in long valley
but also at another property that he
owned in loxahatchee florida
and generally during the course of the
year he and his
people that he was working with and the
horses that he was working with would
train down south in florida during the
winter months when it was too cold to
train in new jersey and then they would
come north in the summer when it was too
hot to train in florida
i expect you'll learn that the defendant
michael barisson ran that business for a
number of years and then he had other
people who worked with them at times
specifically a man named justin hardin
who was his assistant trainer and
did a lot of the day-to-day taking care
of the the property and the farm during
the course of a day making sure that the
arenas were all groomed properly
there were a number of us working
students who would work and live at the
farms and they would take care of the
horses and again take care of some of
the more day-to-day things
but the defendant was really the reason
that people came to that business
because of his success
he had written at the highest levels of
dressage
he had coached other athletes at the
highest levels of dressage and he had
also coached a number of horses and
trained a number of horses throughout
the course of his career
now i'm sure you can all imagine we
didn't ask you all to step away from
your life we didn't put you through jury
service last week we didn't ask you to
come back here and sit on this trial for
the next number of weeks
just to celebrate the defendant and to
hear about his accomplishments as an
equestrian as a coach as a businessman
we ask you to serve on this jury
because of what the defendant is accused
of doing at that property on august 7
2019.
on august 7 2019 he's accused of taking
a gun
leaving that clubhouse that i talked
about
getting into his car in the parking lot
driving up the driveway over that slight
rise coming into the back uh parking lot
where the farmhouse is
getting out with that gun
confronting two people who were living
in the farmhouse
pointing the gun at the woman lauren
canara and shooting her twice in the
chest
then turning the gun on robert goodwin
her boyfriend as he fled into the house
and shooting another shot at robert but
missing
that's the purpose of why we're here for
this trial
now
i'll pause for a moment just to mention
that i'm not going to tell you every
detail about this case during the course
of my opening there are things that i'm
intentionally leaving out and that's
because of something the judge told you
last week during jury selection
something he told you this morning and
he'll tell you that again i'm sure at
least one more time before the trial is
over
what i say
what mr belinkus may say
is not evidence
the evidence doesn't come from the
attorneys it doesn't come from the judge
the evidence will come
from that seat right there
the witness stand
the witnesses who come through that door
take an oath to tell you the truth
and then any evidence that the judge
allows to be admitted
so if i'm leaving certain things out
that's intentional at this point because
the purpose of my opening is just to
give you something of a road map or some
way of what you know what to expect is
going to be coming with some of the
other witnesses who testify
now you heard me mention lauren kanreck
and rob goodman and they were living at
the farm as i said during the summer of
2019
and i expect you'll come to learn that
lauren was also a uh rider
she was uh an equestrian who rode uh
different forms of horses during the
course of her life but she at that time
in her life was training for dressage
and she hoped that she would achieve a
higher level of training and so she
wanted to work with the defendant
because of his reputation
she owned a number of horses that she
was stabling there and as you can
imagine
the best things in life are not free so
she was of course paying the defendant
for the opportunity to work with him and
to have her coaches uh her horses
coached by him
and so you'll hear how she was doing
that there in a time she would work with
justin harden the defendant's other
trainer
and at times she would work with the
defendant's girlfriend mary haskinsgref
you'll come to hear how mary haskins was
also being coached by the defendant she
had aspirations to reach these higher
levels
mary haskins and the defendant also
owned a number of forces together and
you hear that at times
orin was asked to work with mary haskins
and to have mary haskins work with her
now as you can imagine what i just told
you about august 7th 2019 didn't happen
because the training was going well it
didn't happen because things between
these people was all perfect
i think it's way to the contrary you're
going to hear about how bad things work
at hawthorne hill in august of 2019.
you'll hear about how the defendant and
his girlfriend mary haskins were
hassling and giving a hard time to
warren rob and you'll hear how lauren
and rob were giving a hard time back and
hassling back to the defendant and mary
haskins
you're going to hear how they were
really arguing in an almost daily basis
at that point how the police had been
called out to the property starting july
31st on almost a daily basis because
these people just could not get along
you'll even hear about how not just the
defendant and his girlfriend mary
haskins but also lauren and rob were
making complaints or reports up to the
highest levels of report the u.s
equestrian federation or foundation
and safe sport which is an agency that
you may have heard of that basically
oversees olympic level sports and tries
to prevent abuse and misconduct by the
coaches or the players or other people
involved so both of these these groups
of people
have it in for one another and they are
making complaints against one another
and they are
add-ons
i mention all of that now in my opening
because it's obviously part of the case
it's something you're going to hear from
the witnesses it's something you'll hear
about
but it's important to remember
something the judge told you last week
something he told you this morning and
something he'll tell you at the end of
the trial
and that's that when you go back to
delivery and when you go
you're asked to return a verdict
it will not be about warren canary
it will not be about rob goodwin it will
not be about mary haskins it will not be
about any other person
except this man
this man the defendant is the one on
trial
so you may hear things that you don't
like about warren or rob or mary haskins
or any of these other people
but saying nasty things
misbehaving if you want to call it that
none of that is a justification to get
shot
none of it creates a necessity for that
person to be killed
no we're here on this trial because of
the defendant's choice on august 7 2019
his choice to get a gun a pink and black
nine millimeter handgun
to point that gun at lauren and pull the
trigger twice and then to turn it on rob
and pull the trigger again
now i imagine some of you are probably
wondering about that pink and black
handgun and it's obviously an unusual
description for a handgun so you
probably have some questions about where
that handgun came from why did the
defendant have it and i hope and expect
that during the course of the trial
you're going to find that out
there's another woman
who owned horses at the defendant's farm
and her name is ruth cox
and ruth cox is a resident of north
carolina you're going to hear how she
owned horses with the defendant she
owned horses with his girlfriend mary
haskins and how she would travel north
to new jersey every couple of weeks to
check on the horses she would travel
south to florida during the winter
months to check on the horses she would
go to horse shows and see how the horse
was competing
and you'll hear how she got here to new
jersey
to the farm
on about august 2nd so several days
before the shooting is in
i expect you'll hear that at some point
between then
and the day of the shooting she was
alone with the defendant in the stables
and he asked her for her gun
which was a pink and black nine
millimeter handgun
i expect to hear that she gave him that
handgun that it was in the case that it
was unloaded
and that she gave him that handgun and
didn't see it again
until after the shooting
i also expect you'll hear
that dr cox was
ruth cox was charged with a crime as a
result of that that she was charged with
unlawful transfer of a firearm
so that brings me back to august 7th the
day of the shooting
what led to the shooting on that day at
that time if things were so bad between
these people why did the shooting happen
on august 7th
do i expect you'll hear that a
caseworker from the division of child
and permanency and protection sometimes
called dcp or deifus or child services
came to the farm in that early afternoon
as a result of the complaint that had
been made to safe sport
i expect to appear that the caseworker
pulled down that long driveway that she
pulled into that parking lot
and the very first person that she met
outside the clubhouse or the stable was
the defendant
she didn't tell him anything about why
she was there just that she needed to
speak with mary haskins the defendant's
girlfriend
that's because the defendant's
girlfriend mary haskins had two children
who would occasionally live at the farm
or come stay at the farm if they were on
a break from school or something else
the caseworker mary haskins then went
into the office that i described inside
of that clubhouse and they were meeting
in there
and i expect you'll hear that the
defendant came in and interrupted them
first once then a second time and the
third time he interrupted them he told
the two women that he needed the office
that they needed to continue their
conversation in another part of the
property and so they left the office and
left him alone in that office
that office is where the defendant's gun
safe was
and i expect you'll hear that after the
shooting when the police were
investigated
on the top shelf of that safe
they found a black and pink
gun case the same gun case that ruth cox
had given the gun to the defendant i
expect you'll also hear that on the
shelf below it
there was an open box of nine millimeter
ammunition that was also open with a
number of bullets missing
so after the caseworker and mary haskins
left the office and the defendant was
alone in the office it was shortly after
that
that he got into his car in the parking
lot he drove that truck up over the rise
on the driveway and pulled into that
parking lot behind the farmhouse
where he knew
that lauren and ron
i expect the evidence will show
that rob first spoke with the defendant
while rob was standing on the porch and
that there's a large bush next to the
doorway area
such that rob really couldn't see
anything from below the defendant's
chest or so
and that he he the defendant
said word something to the effect of how
do we end this without a war
i expect you'll hear that lauren then
came out of the house or lauren was
walking down the steps of the
porch and that's when the defendant
pulled out the gun and shot her twice
puncturing her lung causing massive
internal bleeding life-threatening
injuries
that she was fortunate enough to survive
and that's why this is an attempted
murder case
you'll hear that rob was able to subdue
the defendant and hold him on the ground
until the police got there because
lauren was able to call 9-1-1 after
she'd been shot
again there are many details that i'm
leaving out this is just a rough sketch
of what i expect you'll hear during the
trial but hopefully it gives you an idea
of what to expect over the next couple
weeks
the last thing i want to mention before
i sit down is the law
now
hearing the evidence hearing the facts
would mean nothing to you if you didn't
have law to apply it to
and i'm imagining that the way that this
case will will move and progress is
going to dictate what law the judge
gives you at the end of the trial
but i can tell you about two parts of
the law that are interconnected that i
virtually guarantee that the judge will
tell you at the end of the trial
i have to say if i say anything
different from what the judge tells you
at the end of the trial as you know he's
the judge of the law he gives you the
law it doesn't come from me it doesn't
come from mr bulingus it doesn't come
from any witness who may testify the law
only comes from the judge but i think
it's important to highlight these two
parts of the law now so you have an idea
of what to expect as you're hearing that
testimony and hearing that evidence
the first thing
is that the burden of proving the
defendant guilty of those crimes
attempted murder and possession of a
weapon for an unlawful purpose
that rests on state
you recall mr bennett and i introduced
ourselves to you during jury selection
last week that is our burden to prove
that burden to prove him guilty
will never shift to the defense
it's a heavy burden as the judge said
beyond a reasonable doubt but it doesn't
mean beyond every battle
and what i expect mr bennett and i will
do over the course of the next days and
weeks is call witnesses and present you
with evidence that will leave you firmly
convinced that the defendant committed
these crimes
evidence that you can rely on
to make your verdict without any passion
any sympathy any prejudice any of those
things the judge mentioned that your
verdict will be based on the evidence
that we produce
the second part of the law that i want
to mention
is connected to that
and that's about the two charges that
the defendant is on trial for
now there are two victims so there's two
counts of each of these charges but the
first charge possession of a weapon for
an unlawful purpose
means that his possession the
defendant's possession of that pink and
black
handgun on august 7th
was unlawful
because he had an intention to use it or
a purpose to use it unlawfully
against rob or against lauren and
shooting
the other charge attempted murder
requires mr bennett and i to prove to
you beyond a reasonable doubt that the
defendant took a substantial step
to cause their deaths
now if you remember back to jury
selection last week and i know for some
of you that was a full week ago some
people mentioned that they like to watch
uh crime procedurals on tv some people
like the dramas
dramatization some people like the the
true life the documentaries but the one
thing that everyone acknowledged was
that the law on tv
is not the same as it is in real life
and certainly the law can change and be
different from state to state
so that's why judge taylor will give you
the law at the end of the trial that
applies here in new
jersey i mentioned that because some of
you
may have had a preconception or a notion
that murder or attempted murder
requires evidence of planning or
preparation or premeditation
but a person can commit even the most
terrible crime
under the influence of an impulse an
impulse that impacts their restraint
that causes them to ignore that
restraint that may ordinarily stop them
or prevent them from committing a crime
from committing murder
but in that moment of emotion in that
moment of impulse they ignore the
ability to tell the difference between
right and wrong they ignore the ability
to understand what they're doing
and commit that act anyway
so even though it may not have been an
act that was preconceived or
premeditated or planned out in great
detail long before that the person can
still act with purpose
the last thing i want to mention about
the law is connected to that as well
and that's that i expect the judge will
tell you that you can infer a
defendant's purpose was to take a life
was to kill
if that person used a deadly weapon a
handgun
now again in this case you'll be
instructed a handgun is a deadly weapon
and i expect you to hear evidence that
the defendant did use that deadly weapon
against loring and against rob and so
you can use that alone to infer that his
intent
was to cause death
i expect the evidence to show that on
august 7th of 2019
the defendant was angry he was furious
he was frustrated he was upset he was
angry with lauren and he was angry with
rob
he knew what he was doing when he went
into that safe he knew what he was doing
when he loaded bullets into the gun he
knew what he was doing when he left the
clubhouse drove down that driveway and
pulled into the parking lot to confront
them
and he most certainly knew what he was
doing was wrong when he pointed the gun
at them and tried to kill them
i'm sure that i'll have more to say at
the end of the trial i want to thank
everyone for your attention this morning
thank you all for being here i
appreciate it and at the end of the
trial mr bennett and i will ask you to
find the defendant guilty of attempted
murder
thank you thank you mr shellhorn